it's not happened before at least in
living memory a British prime minister
refusing to meet a Greek one and on the
subject of a national cause the
reunification of the Parthenon marbles
being held in the British museum with
those remaining in Athens when it was
clear that the purpose of a meeting was
not to discuss substantive issues for
the future but rather to grandstand and
relitigate issues of the pass it wasn't
appropriate in the shadow of the
Acropolis Museum built 14 years ago
specific Aly to house the reunited
collection Greeks were
incensed it was unheard of behavior from
a British prime minister to a colleague
from the European Union Greek Prime
Minister kirakos mitsotakis made light
of it saying the snub had backfired
giving the path non Marble's more Global
publicity but there were other topics
the two leaders didn't get to discuss as
a result like migration no I think this
was quite unexpected and surprised us
unpleasantly and caused a negative
impression here I think sunak and the
Tories face a popularity problem a few
months before general elections and he
wanted to make an impression Greece has
been asking for its marbles back in
Earnest for at least four decades and
the vast majority of Greek society
supports that cause this government has
been pushing hard for a deal that would
lend the British museum other Treasures
in return for the Marble's permanent
repatriation Lord elen's removal of the
sculptures was controversial from the
moment it happened more than two
centuries ago and no one here expects a
quick solution but the Greeks did at
least expect the courtesy of being heard
John copulos Al jazer
Athens make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaera